hello everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram angle from Washington tonight
Klaus and the Gang that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now the Associated Press which was once
considered the gold standard in
reporting
a little more than a glorified print
version of MSNBC
they've gone from keeping powerful
interests in check to protecting them at
all costs
so when the globalists at the world
economic Forum need cover they know
where to turn
the poor billionaires all they want to
do is kick around their plans for saving
the planet and instead the AP says their
event has become a target of bizarre
claims for those who believe a group of
Elites are manipulating Global events
for their own benefit the great reset
has become shorthand on conservative
talk shows for what Skeptics say is a
reorganization of society okay hey
fellas at the AP hate to break a TIA but
the truth is not a conspiracy
now what does the word reset really mean
if it's not a reordering of what came
before
I was trying to add up the time earlier
today but I think it's for more than 20
years now I've been reporting on afar
from Davos but now they're apparently
offended when we're literally just
quoting them and playing the videos that
they've posted online because look if
you quote them and post their videos
it's all disinformation
and apparently they've mysteriously
removed some of their more controversial
videos recently
if you look at at this question of
disinformation
I think it Maps basically to every other
major challenge that we are grappling
with this society and particularly the
most existential among them conspiracy
propaganda click bait you know the the
the broader
um mix of bad information that what it
attacks is Trust
professor doesn't seem to Fathom is that
the elites brought this on themselves
now the reason the public doesn't trust
the media establishment like that guy or
the corporate establishment the public
health establishment is because they've
long ago ceased being honest Brokers
they've become rank partisans and of
course committed globalists
so how is it that a bunch of Brave
doctors were the first to expose the
problems with those mRNA covet shots
why did the gray lady dismiss the hunter
Biden laptop story out of hand
another conspiracy they called it police
now remember the elites even our own
media they really don't like your free
speech because if your views are
contrary to theirs and your views are
passionately expressed
it's going to be described as
disinformation misinformation a
conspiracy theory or their favorite hate
speech
and the European commission for values
and transparency want their rules to
apply here
we need the people who understand the
language and the case law in the country
because what qualifies as hate speech
as illegal hate speech which you will
have soon also in the U.S I think that
we we have a strong reason why we have
this in the criminal law
glad stelter got a job well Klaus Schwab
the founder of the world economic Forum
of course agrees but he wants to know
that look all of this is for your own
good
our global economy is undergoing deep
transformation
the energy transmission
see consequences of Kobe
see reshaping of Supply chains
are all serving as Catholic forces
for the economic transformation and the
most critical fragmentation is between
those who take a constructive attitude
and souls
who are just bystanders but the spirit
of tables is positive it's constructive
now when he says fragmentation what he
really means is differing opinion and
the Davos crowd wants none of that
because the elites who want to reorder
Society they're always positive always
constructive and any of you who disagree
with what it will require to achieve
this sustainable Greener Planet you're
always destructive negative very
negative
yet the deflectors in the Press Corps
they're not interested in the truth
because if they were they'd be digging
into the true cost of all this achieving
that the elites want of their vision of
a cleaner more Equitable world
and while we're at it why should we
assume pure motives on the part of the
world economic Forum panelists I think
cloud Schwab does sound like a bond
villain
if someone like ESG champion Larry Fink
constantly makes excuses for and defends
China where they literally enslave
religious minorities and dissenters
why should we listen to anything he says
even in the first letter when I talked
about
um decarbonization and climate that was
in 2020 and all the things I've said are
still true today if you do not have a
lens towards a decarbonization you're
not going to win one
Euro business a transition has to always
be fair and just
all right how did Larry get to Davos by
the way in his solar jet
and how does Larry run his offices with
wind power
now he fancies himself the
self-appointed moralist of the green
agenda the drivers of sustainability and
profit but he's just a fraud
because in his Fantasy Land the little
guy always gets shafted
his job gets shipped to China he has to
sell his favorite truck he can't afford
a day at Disney let alone a week at
Davos
and let's not forget the globalists have
always been partial to Europe
because let's face it technocrats
essentially run the EU the people have
limited say they're slow to resist
agendas forced upon them like Angela
merkel's decision to flood the region
with an influx of Islamic refugees not
popular they didn't do anything about it
and of course the Davos devotees love
China Klaus and the Gang they don't care
that they're the world's biggest
polluter and that China continues to
build coal plants in fact they see the
CCP as a very valuable partner since
China's up and reform process over 40
years ago
the county has made great contributions
to the development of the global economy
we have to understand China is the
number one driver of clean energy today
with all it is right yeah we've got to
cooperate with them obviously now
obviously we obviously have to cooperate
with them now they completely ignore the
fact that since China was admitted to
the World Trade Organization they've
become if anything more not less
oppressive but of course none of that
matters to the elites
then there is America
now we are by our nature Rebels we test
theories we challenge hypotheses we
question motives
and our Founders understood that free
inquiry was needed and we had to protect
it in order for us to remain free and an
independent nation
in a world of sheep we've been Shepherds
we go our own way to protect our flocks
and when push comes to shove we won't
hesitate generally to shove the elites
against the wall if they start
encroaching on our freedom
but with Biden in the White House the
Davos crowd thinks they have an opening
he's their useful idiot
but they know they may have only a
two-year window to co-opt America and
Advance their initiatives
the end is we have to save this planet
to save our freedom and the way we are
living and we are not good enough yet we
have to improve I
have
growth
already and I'll leave it at that no
more development none for you no more
growth it's back to the Stone Age
well beneath all their breathless
blather about sustainability and Global
Equity lies the truth about the
globalist real goals
look we're not experiencing a planetary
emergency they're experiencing a power
emergency meaning theirs is in jeopardy
protecting their own purchase of
influence and money consolidating their
power by any means necessary is their
aim
so your modes of transportation your
food sources how you cook your food your
right to self-defense your right to free
speech even your right to own property
would be sacrificed for the greater good
but just remember this
Klaus and the Gang's greatest hits are
only popular among a small slice slice
of left-wing Fanatics and Elites who fly
to Davos to Virtue signal on the way to
the caviar and Cristal
in two years America is going to have a
new leader who puts America First and
the Davos doofuses on notice
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else